là on s'en va je tremble égide courage
qui me rendent dans le ventre ingrid
falaise était visiblement très ému lors
du dévoilement de l'émission le monstre
son histoire porté à l'écran j'ai
extrêmement vulnérables en ce moment
l'écrire le vivre c'est une chose mais
de la voie d'en face et c'est très très
très dur
victime de violences conjugales ingrid
falaise a raconté son histoire d'horreur
dans un livre en 2015
son récit avait touché beaucoup de gens
et il s'est vendu à plus de 75000
exemplaires
je me suis protégé en six épisodes la
série le monstre relate la période où
elle a vécu sous emprise de manipulateur
violence
c'est rose marie perrot qui incarne une
griffe à l'aise c'est la magie c'est
poche juste une histoire de violence
conjugale c'est aussi une histoire
d'amour ce qui est assez bizarre puis
difficile à accepter même que tu m'as
manqué s'il y a des moments prétendre
d'autres scènes sont très dur à regarder
comme les toutes premières secondes de
la série
[Applaudissements]
les étés déduction de chaque journée
désir jusque où on montre sans carla
papa voyeurisme pas par complaisance par
désire quelque part d'être sûr que les
spectateurs ressentent profondément ce
qui s'est passé tu devrais partir les
scènes de violence ont été les plus
difficiles à jouer surtout pour celui
qui incarne le bourreau du parti
confiant c'est très difficile on a beau
se préparer autant qu'on veut on n'est
jamais prêt il ya tellement une dose
d'adrénaline qui qui qui viennent
chercher quand tu les fais ses singles
est tellement intense qui est des fois
après le coupé l'élan s'est passé j'ai
trouvé ça difficile de m'en remettre
c'est sûr qu'on sait que la série sera
disponible sur l'extra de tou.tv dès
jeudi
ingrid falaise qui a déjà brisé le
silence avec son livre veut aller encore
plus loin avec l'adaptation télévisuelle
je veux que les gens comprennent que ça
commence pas du jour au lendemain avec
un coup de poing dans face je me
souviens bien je l'accepté ici julie
jasmin boudreau radio-canada à montréal